certo
l'autore si trova sulla luna a camminare
e vede vede gli incontro un uomo nudo è
perplesso ma decide di indugiare di
aspettare fino a quando in quest uomo
nudo non gli si avvicina allora lui gli
chiede ma mi spieghi il motivo per cui
va in giro facendo sfoggio delle tue
parti basse e l'uomo lunare che fa
girando per le strade nudo gli dice ti
sembra più normale fare quello che
faccio io esponendo un organo che
provoca piacere e vita o è preferibile
fare come fai tu sulla terra in cui va
in giro esponendo spade e strumenti di
uccisione e di tortura è un libro questo
da cui vi cito questo passaggio che si
chiama l'altro mondo
l'autore cyrano de bergerac in questo
libro accadono altri fatti
uno di questi ad esempio e che nasce la
figura del fisionomia che è il medico
dei sani qualcuno che va a curare il non
essere quasi in vita di chi pensa di
stare bene che tutto sia facile e non
prova quella fragile dimensione della
vita che è tipica di chi è
effettivamente è sensibilmente in vita
questi piccoli passaggi mi servono per
introdurre il tema di cui vi parlerò
oggi che il tema della fantasia del
fantastico e il tema del ruolo che la
fantasia nella nostra vita ed è un tema
rispetto al quale vorrei proporvi una
sorta di controcanto una contro idea
rispetto a quelle che nei luoghi comuni
hanno preso radici relativamente alla
questione
molti di noi pensano che fantasticare
equivalga a evadere ad andare altrove e
allo stesso tempo attribuiscono al tema
del fantasticare qualcosa che è prossimo
alla gratuità all'inutilità al superfluo
ecco sono qui per proporre un modo
diverso di pensare la fantasia e per
farlo prima di tutto bisogno di
dirvi quali sono le cinque tecniche su
cui ogni procedimento fantastico si
sviluppa la prima tecnica si chiama
tecnica del capovolgimento è una tecnica
rispetto alla quale ognuno di noi nelle
condizioni di salutare delle balene in
cielo dire a un amico che non può
raggiungerlo perché si ritrovava nei
miei piedi è una tecnica in cui esulta
chi perde e soffre chi vince è una
tecnica in cui contro ogni miseria ogni
dimensione asfittica della vita gli
uomini si sono inventati il paese di
cuccagna e la tecnica attraverso la
quale contro ogni rigore e regola
schiacciante dell'umano
qualcuno si è inventato il paese dei
balocchi un gioco a mettere sottosopra
un gioco a dire che le regole che ci
stiamo dando rispetto al qui
probabilmente non tengono conto fino in
fondo dell'umano e dovrebbero essere
riscritte riviste bisognerebbe
riproporre formule nuove la seconda
tecnica e la tecnica della combinazione
cos'è una combinazione vi siete mai
chiesti che cos'è un serpe strillo un
papà drillo sono esseri straordinari che
rispondono a un assolutamente naturale
tentativo dell'uomo di mettere insieme
una cosa è una cosa è far nascere una
cosa ennesima che non credeva potesse
esistere è una cosa rispetto alla quale
ogni uomo mette insieme un io è un tool
e fa nascere qualcosa di incredibilmente
potente come posso può essere
un'amicizia un amore un incontro un
dialogo ed è qualcosa che gli uomini in
controcanto all'alzata alle alzate dei
muri offrono agli altri come segno della
reciprocità che spesso e volentieri in
questo tempo frettoloso abbiamo perso
andiamo avanti
un giorno mi è capitato di incontrare un
uomo conchiglia era un uomo che al posto
dell'orecchio si ritrovava una
conchiglia che appartiene da quel
momento non riusciva più ad ascoltare
gli altri
traducendo il loro linguaggio nella nel
linguaggio che comunemente parliamo noi
ma ha iniziato a tradurre gli incontri
degli altri nei moti ondosi del suo
ascolto per cui quando vede gli altri
che si abbracciano e si vogliono bene
sente il bagnasciuga baciato dalle onde
dolcissime del mare e quando invece vede
gli altri aggredirsi e graffiarsi sente
il mare in tempesta divorare ogni cosa e
impennarsi fino alle stelle per tirarle
giù e chiudere tutto sul respiro
affannato degli uomini
ho visto donne antenna ho visto uomini
che hanno le mani e fanno le carezze
all'amata ma se avessero una ruota
potrebbero dire mi fai fare un viaggio
nel tuo profilo
e se avessero una lampadina direbbero
vorrei mettere in luce la tua bellezza
ho visto uomini che a un certo punto
hanno inventato donne che al posto dei
capelli avevano i serpenti ed è nata
medusa
ho visto mettere delle cose al posto di
altre cose e tirare fuori effetti
fantastici
poi ho visto ho visto anche altro ho
visto ad esempio draghi dalle mille test
riconosciamo tutti ma abbiamo visto
anche uomini con un occhio solo c'era
insegnato liszt che è possibile
incontrarli
abbiamo visto delle abbiamo ascoltato
dalla notte dei nostri tempi delle
canzoncine come per fare un tavolo ci
vuole il legno
conosciamo tutti e di rodari usa una
tecnica che quella della serialità che
lavora sulle catene dei concetti come
mai uno sciopero di gatti provoca il
disboscamento dell'abetone molto
semplice i gatti decidono di non
mangiare più topi topi proliferano e pro
quando mangiano sempre più formaggio
mangiando più formaggio costringono a
produrre sempre più formaggio a mangiare
sempre più coraggio fino a quando viene
disboscato l'abetone parto da un fatto
assurdo lontanissimo e mettendo insieme
grazie alla nostra intelligenza
i pezzi viene fuori una linea
straordinaria che ha un rigore logico
potentissimo ed è una tecnica rispettata
quale l'uomo spiritualmente ha bisogno
di vedere la vita nascere dalla vita ha
bisogno e anche paura però di vedere il
male nascere dal male il desiderio di
proliferazione
ma anche la paura della metastasi ci
sono tanti aspetti rispetto ai quali il
fantastico interviene e in un certo
senso culla abbraccia stringe le ansie
degli uomini ultima tecnica a proposito
di anzi degli uomini a che fare con le
trasformazioni chi chi ha letto di
mitologia conosce benissimo le infinite
trasformazioni di zeus per conquistare
uno dei miei racconti preferiti tratti
tratto dalle metamorfosi di ovidio che è
una mia bibbia parla di una
straordinaria coppia che risponde al
nome di filemone e bauci zeus hermes
vanno in mezzo agli uomini vestendosi da
pellegrini e li mettono alla prova
chiedendo loro di essere accolti dopo un
viaggio faticoso alla luce della loro
stanchezza abissale ma bussano a tutte
le porte nessuno apre fino a quando
nella più precaria e nella più fragile
delle abitazioni una capanna bussano
lievemente per evitare che tutto crolli
dalla porta arrivano due persone che si
chiamano fine monet e bauci e chiedono
cosa c'è si sentono dire abbiamo fame
abbiamo sete è possibile mangiare bere
qualcosa da voi e loro dicono abbiamo
pochissimo ma se il nostro pochissimo va
bene diventa per tutti
accomodatevi è loro mangiano poi vanno a
riposare e poi si risvegliano e al
risveglio fanno cenno di ascoltare
quello che sta per accadere
e accade questo un violento terremoto
scuote ogni cosa e fa crollare tutte le
case lasciando in piedi
l'unica precaria abitazione di quei due
che sconvolti chiedono cosa sta
succedendo ma è arrivato il momento
anche per loro di sapere i due tolgo
nuove vesti da pellegrini e dicono non
avete ospitato due stranieri
avete ospitato due divinità perché dalle
note dalla notte delle nostre narrazioni
oggi si apre una porta a prà dio agli
dei e dice si sentono dire cosa volete
per ricompensa avrete tutto quello che
volete e loro dicono a volte incontro i
bambini e gli chiedo chi indovina vince
un mio libro allora iniziano a dire una
casa più bella e il frigorifero il
televisore i soldi ma loro rispondono
questo sia il nostro desiderio è che
quando tutto dovrà compiersi
vorremmo andare via né lo stesso
identico istante evitando la tragedia di
sopravvivere l'uno all'altro anche le
due divinità sono sorprese però dicono
va bene sarà fatto passare il tempo
tornano e quando loro tornano e bussano
le loro capiscono che è arrivato e sanno
che tutto sta per compiersi non tornano
dentro casa ma escono fuori iniziano a
salutarsi dicendosi fino alla fine
l'amore che li ha accompagnati per tutta
la vita sei bellissima anche adesso e
dovresti vederti tu mi ha emozionato più
del sole e tu più della pioggia mentre
si salutano iniziano a trasformarsi in
tronchi intrecciati per i piedi fino a
quando di filiano e bauci non restano
che due alberi sui quali con velocità
assoluta agli uccelli prendono la mira
per andare a posizionare i veronesi a
filemone e bauci ci insegnano che l'uomo
di fronte alla paura della morte ha
bisogno di inventarsi forme nuove e di
pensare quando finirà la nostra forma
quale altra forma assumerà e quindi
nascono queste storie nascono le parole
che vanno a prendere dal fondo del della
non esistenza come off con euridice lo
scomparse lo riportano alla vita e
arriviamo alle conclusioni
capovolgimenti combinazioni sostituzioni
serialità e trasformazioni il fantastico
non è un esercizio gratuito in prima
battuta non è un esilio dalla vita
perché il fantastico è una pianta che
nasce sui rami da della realtà lo
presuppone ne ha bisogno deve dialogare
con la realtà
se non sapessi che gli uomini hanno due
occhi polifemo non sarebbe un mostro e
se non sapessi che hanno i capelli non
esisterebbe medusa quindi fantastico non
si mette a dire la realtà non è ma si
mette a dire è e io germogliando prova a
trasformarsi nella misura in cui
utilizzando queste tecniche che sono
facoltà di tutti non dono di alcuni
qualcuno prova a riformulare il senso
del tragitto del suo pensiero
inevitabilmente accade che vedrà in una
luce nuova il mondo e nella misura in
cui vede il mondo con una luce nuova il
mondo con una luce nuova
arriverà a lui e avrà prodotto una
trasformazione perché gli uomini non
sono solo se solo ci sono sempre in
relazione sono qui rispetto all'altro
sono progettati nel mondo e questo io lo
porto anche nella mia vita facendo dei
capovolgimenti rispetto all'idea di uno
scrittore ad esempio non sopporto gli
scrittori che vanno in giro gonfi perché
a dispetto di chi esaspera le capacità
di uno scrittore uno scrittore in realtà
mettendo le cose sotto sopra è uno
straordinario manifesto della fragilità
e dell'incompiutezza io non esisto con i
segni che ho depositato su una pagina se
tu non viene non li prendi io sono un
essere lunare il sole se tu che mi dà
alla luce
e poi c'è la mia dimensione e potente
che quella della solidarietà e del
volontariato
la solidarietà è un mondo che prova a
mettere sottosopra il mondo
prova a offrire un canto diverso
rispetto al quale contro la logica
dell'accumulo e del prof
scritto suggerisce la meravigliosa e
dispendiosa dimensione del dono e della
condivisione contro la frettolosa
incapacità di trovare uno spazio e un
tempo perché si avverino gli incontri il
volontariato e la solidarietà dicono io
sono qui tu dove sei
nella misura in cui il volontariato e la
solidarietà trovano la capacità di
andare a trovare il senso più pieno e
più alto della vita negli ultimi nei
fragili quelli che corrono il rischio
dalla vita di essere estromessi bene il
volontariato e la solidarietà per me che
sono uno scrittore e solidale giocano un
ruolo straordinariamente fantastico in
grado di proporre un modo nuovo di
abitare più umanamente questo mondo
grazie